around 9 000 people land every day at
heathrow despite the pandemic
soon some won't be going far once they
touch
down ten months into the outbreak hotel
quarantine will become compulsory
for uk and irish nationals and residents
arriving from selected
high-risk countries and anyone leaving
the uk
will have to declare a valid reason and
holidays
still don't count even for those who
claim it's their job
we see plenty of influences on social
media showing off about which parts of
the world that they are in mainly in
sunny parts of the world going on
holiday is not
is not um is not an exemption and it's
important that people stay at home
today's announcement is too limited it
leaves huge gaps in our defenses against
emerging strains
the sofitel he throws terminal 5 is
preparing for quarantined arrivals
it already has a testing facility that's
part of ba cabin's crew's pre-flight
routine
airport hotels are uniquely placed
because we often deal with
travel disruption and delayed flights
and we can very quickly ramp up
our hotels this hotel the sofitel has
600 bedrooms
it could go from 200 bedrooms to 600
bedrooms on a phone call and
with just an hour's notice from the
airline arrivals will be brought
straight to their rooms
and confined to the four walls for 10
days
anyone in hotel quarantine is
effectively in a gilded cage at their
own expense but
managing them is a major logistical
exercise everyone
needs 24-hour room service they'll need
full ppe
just to change a light bulb somehow
these corridors need to be policed
if it's going to work in melbourne peter
mcdonald is quarantined in a
government-nominated hotel for a
fortnight
being in air conditioning for two weeks
is going to be pretty brutal
australia one of a host of countries
that have contained outbreaks more
effectively
than the uk australia's very lucky we're
very lucky to hear
how things have gone and this is one of
the reasons why we're in the position we
are
is because this is helping to stop the
spread and if i can
spend 14 days in here and it stops me
from potentially spreading this
this virus around then you know so bad
britain's repatriated from wuhan in
china in the first wave were quarantined
but the vast majority of cases
arrived from europe and experts say the
border
is vulnerable it's only a matter of time
before there will be
a variant somewhere in the world that
will evade it
and what we want is for our country to
be vaccinated and protected from that
um before it happens now that means that
i think at least we need border control
for at least a year
title restrictions are another blow to
the travel industry
but every exception at the border is an
opportunity
for the virus paul kelso sky news at
heathrow